Turkey's strong man had looked
invincible but then seemingly from
nowhere and uprising against him in the
form of an attempted coup president erdo
wan's 13-year rule defined by growing
authoritarianism appeared to be over as
the night skies filled with the sound of
jets he is undoubtedly a polarizing
figure revered by his followers but
hated by liberal Turkey the government
claims the rebellious factions in the
military were orchestrated by petula
Gulen the reclusive former ally of
president Erdogan who is now in
self-imposed exile at his headquarters
in the United States denies the
accusations but his hizmet movement does
have millions of devoted followers in
Turkey many have key positions in the
police and the Judiciary this is what
Iran's government means when they talk
of shadowy forces operating within the
system Erdogan came to power in 2003 and
has spent the last few years bolstering
his presidential remit his critics see
him as an enemy of democracy basic
rights have been curtailed with protests
sometimes violence staged against the
suppression of press freedom and
political debate turkey is also
suffering from a rise in terrorist
attacks odo and Syria policy is blamed
by many for destabilizing the nation
it's claimed he has empowered extremist
groups like Isis by using jihadists as a
proxy to battle President Assad and
stymie Iranian influence in the region
the unrest in Turkey then is massively
worrying for the West cooperation with
Ankara is vital on dealing with issues
such as the refugee crisis which has
seen hundreds of thousands of desperate
people wash up on Europe
turkey is also crucially a member of
NATO its military the second largest in
the Alliance support for President
durance government's which was
democratically elected has been coming
in from around the world as of this
moment Turkey's cooperation with us in
our counterterrorism efforts in our NATO
obligations and in our regional efforts
with respect to Syria and Isis have not
been affected negatively all of that has
continued as before the failed coup has
opened up huge fishes in Turkey's
political fabric in the short term
democracy people on the streets
defeating men with guns is the winner
but in the long term freedom will likely
be the loser as president erdo and
strengthens his hold on the country and
cracks down on any and all dissent Alex
Rossi Sky News